we are starting today with the United
States Senate we still don't know who
controls it we still don't know who will
control it but there is going to be a
runoff in the state of Georgia on
December 6th between Raphael Warnock and
Challenger Herschel Walker this may be
the race that decides who controls the
Senate let's set it up and tell you
where we are right now at this point in
time based on the seats that have been
determined definitively it is Democrats
48 and Republicans 49 in the Senate
remember Democrats need only 50 for a
majority because Kamala Harris the vice
president would be the 51st vote a
tiebreaker in the event of any 50 50
Deadlock it is quite possible
it is possible that Democrats won't
actually need Georgia why do I say that
well in Arizona Mark Kelly the incumbent
Democrat is five points ahead of Blake
Masters the uh horrible Republican
Challenger with 76 percent of the vote
in is it possible Masters could still
win there it is is it likely no this
race when it is hopefully called for
Mark Kelly will put Democrats at 49. you
then have the state of Nevada
in Nevada the incumbent Cortez masto is
running 1.8 points behind Adam laxalt
but experts who are looking county by
county at what is outstanding in Nevada
say this may end up being a defeat for
Adam laxalt because even though 84
percent of the vote is counted the 16
that is left favors Cortez Master the
question is will it favor her enough for
her to make up 1.8 points we don't know
the answer
if indeed Cortez masto pulls this out
that's 50. and the Georgia race becomes
for 51 which would make Kamala Harris's
tie-breaking vote unnecessary but we
can't count on that it is totally
plausible that control of the Senate
will depend on a December 6 runoff in
Georgia why is there a runoff if you
look at the results Rafael Warnock won
well Georgia has what's called the 50
threshold rule If no candidate gets to
50 percent a runoff will be held between
the top two candidates and indeed
because there is a third party candidate
in Georgia Oliver who got a hair over
two percent of the vote although Raphael
Warnock won by 1.3 points nearly 50 000
votes there will be a runoff this is the
race
in which we must now get involved I
don't know that I can make it down to
Georgia in the next few weeks but we are
going to try to see what we can do at a
distance can we do live streams
fundraising for Raphael Warnock and
maybe get matching funds set up well
we'll take a look can we do some kind of
live group Mass phone banking or at
least get people signed up to phone bank
or something like that we're going to
see what can we do this is a race of
critical importance there is a dramatic
difference between Democrats losing the
House and Senate
versus Democrats keeping the Senate but
losing the house yes if Democrats lose
the house they'll probably try to file
articles of impeachment against Joe
Biden they'll obstruct they'll do a
whole bunch of stuff but in particular
when it comes to federal judges
potentially a Supreme Court Justice over
the next two years we don't know
control of the Senate is absolutely
critical so if you live in Georgia
make sure that you're going to vote in
this one your vote quite literally could
decide who controls the senate for the
next two years and who controls the
Senate at the time of the 2024 election
could also impact that presidential race
so we're going to have much more about
this but that is where we are
Herschel Walker
right up there is one of the worst
candidates I've ever seen can barely
speak
can barely explain his position on any
issue a complete and total hypocrite
says he's against abortion in all cases
urged and paid for multiple women to
have abortions says we need you know uh
we we need we need fathers involved in
their kids lives is an absent father
himself pulled out a fake badge during a
debate has no qualifications whatsoever
has no business whatsoever being in the
Senate this is not only about control of
the Senate to some degree this is also
about reducing the level of humiliation
of the United States globally I get
emails from people all over the world
Germany UK Ireland Australia saying
David what is wrong with the United
States
a guy like Walker should be laughed off
any of these stages and no other country
would he even stand a chance and I think
generally speaking those people are
right let's now talk about Lauren bober
if you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plans one
free tree for every plot of land sold
established titles does really good work
all over the world with reforestation
organizations like one tree planted and
trees for the future so you'll have a
great laugh whether you're Scottish or
not I'm not but you're giving the gift
gift of reforestation to fight climate
change if you use my link you'll get 10
percent off and your plot of land will
be right next to mine you can see it on
a map go to establishedtitles.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman for an extra 10
off on top of their Black Friday deal
the link is down below